the DC Universe is broken Superman is
lost Black Adam stayed in the red cyborg
has been silenced Wonder Woman has
vanished Into Thin Air and the Flash has
gotten into so much trouble that DC
wishes he'd just run his way into an
entirely new timeline but there's still
hope for the future my friends and the
key to solving all of it cartoons
hello Internet welcome to film Theory
the show that wants you to subscribe
faster than the flash bet you can't do
it and write your favorite superhero
down in the comments in less than three
seconds three two wait you did it dang
you are faster than a speeding bullet
well done now it might be difficult to
remember but there was a time not too
long ago when DC was the top dog when it
came to superhero movies Remember The
Dark Knight trilogy those movies made
over 2.4 billion dollars at the box
office one of them was so good that when
it wasn't nominated for best picture at
the Oscars the academy literally changed
their rules to avoid anything like that
ever happening again but uh in the
following years yeah yeah not so much
the dceu which officially started with
Man of Steel 10 years ago has been an
absolute mess and that's not meant to be
a judgment call or measure of quality I
mean just as a point of fact right now
there are three different Batman and two
separate Jokers running around at the
same time and that's just the tip of the
iceberg since the dceu started it's been
a nightmare of hiring firing and
rehiring multiple directors for the same
project actor is being let go brought
back again only to be let go again
there's been public Fallout over bad
behavior by Studio Executives constant
cameos and teases for films that'll
never happen while completely finished
movies are just outright canceled
meanwhile you got star actors dealing
with felony allegations popping up like
the worst game a whack-a-mole ever and
the only thing that's dropped further
than the quality of some of these things
is wb's stock price which got so low
that it was basically sold for spare
parts to the guy who runs the Discovery
Channel gotta be honest here loyal
theorists as someone who grew up loving
DC's Heroes more than Marvel's it's been
really heartbreaking to see this but now
there's New Hope Warner Brothers brought
on James Gunn writer and director of
Guardians of the Galaxy The Suicide
Squad and Peacemaker to Shepherd their
movies back to financial and critical
success and while he certainly has a
long path ahead of him to get the DC
Universe back to where it needs to be I
think he can do it provided he follows
my advice today that's right loyal
theorists today I plan to give this new
master of the universe a five-point
guide on how to make a successful DC
cinematic franchise and I'm not just
pulling this from anywhere I have proof
that these steps will work so put on
your super suits and kiss your Martha's
goodbye let's save ourselves a franchise
shall we hey there theorists future
matpat here for the second film theory
in a row go figure so literally just a
couple hours ago as I write this James
Gunn came out and did a big presentation
talking about DC's future plans
announcing 10 new projects for Gods and
Monsters the so-called first chapter of
their big DC reboots mind you this is a
couple days after we wrote and recorded
this and got the audio out to our
editors team's guns announcement kind of
came out of nowhere usually they preface
this sort of stuff or try to time it
around Big Industry events but nope this
was him just dropping a big old
promotional bomb in the middle of
everyone so what I'm gonna be doing now
is laying out my advice exactly as it
was written not changing the script at
all but then at the end of each section
I'm gonna pop back in to assess how guns
seems to be handling things going
forward does it look like he's taken our
advice is he ignoring it and doing his
own thing or is he falling into the
mistakes of his predecessors let's just
jump back into the theory and find out
step number one take care of your Heavy
Hitters both in terms of characters as
well as the talent behind him in pop
culture DC's characters have a pretty
strong brand identity most people know
who's Superman Batman Wonder Woman
Aquaman and the Flash are heck even
Green Lantern so at least to start your
focus needs to be on revitalizing most
of the core cast with strong movies or
series not to say that I don't think a
cyborg or a Black Adam or a birds of
prey can work on screen but why would
people go to see those if you can't even
get Superman right right now DC needs to
rebuild the audience's trust they need
to let him know that they're delivering
fun high quality movies consistently
with all the name brands that we know
and love then and only then will people
start to come out for the second
stringers I mean case in point just look
at Marvel phase one you gotta do your
Captain Americas and Thor's Justice
before anyone gives the talking tree and
Sassy rabbit a chance the Marvel Brand
can carry smaller characters now all
that said the other side of the coin is
after you've done a few of your core
characters Justice if a creative comes
along and has an amazing pitch for
something more obscure run with it you
may end up making c-list characters like
animal man or the Doom Patrol into
household names and we know that DC is
capable of this look no further than
Shazam it had a great story with a
likable tone and a strong cast and now
you're seeing him enter the cultural
Zeitgeist more and more even more
obscure before the suicide squad no one
had ever heard of a peacemaker but now
he's played by a world famous wrestler
and has his own popular TV show my mom
has heard of Peacemaker again Marvel has
routinely done this when they didn't
have the rights to their biggest names
like Spider-Man or the X-Men they looked
at their second stringers the core
Avengers cast used to be the guys that
cameoed in the Spider-Man cartoons now
they're all huge franchises of their own
rights and I don't just mean Iron Man
and Captain America here either they've
turned the Scarlet Witch Shong Chi Moon
Knight and the Guardians the Galaxy into
brands that are big enough to carry
their own films TV shows and theme park
rides Kevin feige's gone on record
saying that when they're deciding which
characters to adapt it doesn't matter
how famous or popular the character is
in the comics only that there's great
potential for a movie story should
always come first alright future map hat
with the assessment so how's gun
handling things well it kind of remains
to be seen though there was a big focus
on projects like the new iterations of
the core cast with Superman Legacy and
the Brave and the Bold there was also a
surprisingly large amount of obscure
stuff thrown in the mix Swamp Thing
Booster Gold still I think gun
understands that they need to get their
Heavy Hitters right he told deadline in
one of the interviews quote one of our
strategies is that we take our Diamond
characters Batman Superman Wonder Woman
and we use that to help prop up other
characters that people don't know and
thus we get ourselves Creature Commandos
So in theory in superhero theory he
seems to get it but we'll see how things
pan out which leads me to my next piece
of advice number two trust the source
material the fans love these characters
and they have loved these characters for
decades there's a reason for that and
it's your job to understand why what is
the core value of that character to the
audience and then once you understand
what that is do not change it there are
so many recent examples of people using
IP without any sort of respect for the
source material isn't that right Velma
for instance Superman the symbol of
truth justice in the American way should
not be destroying whole city blocks or
snap and necks in a gritty drama or if
he is that needs to be the point that is
the dramatic struggle that's the
conflict that the movie has to explore
throughout its run time the character
who's determined to be purely good is
suddenly forced into positions where he
has to question his own ethical line
that that is an interesting movie it's
the superhero version of the trolley
problem dig into that because it plays
into what people love about Superman his
unironic unspoiled sense of pure
goodness and hope don't just leave it as
some sort of footnote to happen at the
end of the film if you want an example
of what not to do take a look at
Netflix's The Witcher it started out
great with Henry Cavill a beloved actor
and fan of the material stepping in to
play the title character but things
quickly devolved as the creatives
started changing parts of the Witcher
Mythos to the point that rumors started
swirling that the writers hated their
Source material that right there is what
we call a big red flag and the fan
reviews for both season 2 and the
spin-off blood Origins reflect that is
it any wonder that Henry Cavill bowed
out of the franchise that he loved so he
could go work on a Warhammer adaptation
he even released a public statement
saying quote I promise to respect this
IP that we love I promise to bring you
something familiar it's not a good look
for the creative team over at The
Witcher huh you have to choose the
Lesser evil in short audiences aren't
dumb they can tell when something's made
with a genuine love for the IP so if you
find out that your writer staff can't be
bothered to pick up and read some comic
books then just stop what you're doing
stop it right there and find a project
that they are excited about or you know
scrap the whole team and get someone who
actually wants the project you know a
character that has some ridiculous lore
Sonic the Hedgehog but both Sonic movies
have embraced that video game weirdness
to deliver movies that are in the top 10
highest grossing for the year they
respected The Source material speaking
of that Sonic lore by the way if you're
interested in just how crazy Sonic lore
gets and how the newest games release
breaks all of it we just released a game
theory about that very topic link is in
the top right corner of the screen make
sure you watch that one after we're done
solving the DC eu's problems future map
Pap back again happy to say that I think
Gunn Nails this point the new Superman
Project seems to be borrowing for more
hopeful Stories the Brave and the Bold
is bringing more of Batman's very
popular family of characters onto the
screen and embracing stranger parts of
the Obscure IP they're adapting awesome
even that Supergirl movie is adapting a
really new really weird story that fans
and critics loved borrowing more from
stuff like John Carter than Smallville
on paper everything here is looking
great which makes a lot of sense I mean
we're talking about a guy who made a
talking raccoon alien tree and polka dot
man work on film if there was any one of
these five points that he was gonna
knock out of the park park it was gonna
be this one now back to the advice Point
number three and this is a bit of a
corollary to what we just talked about
if a character doesn't fit a tone Don't
force him into a movie with that tone
basically I don't want to try to ram a
Superman shaped block through a
batman-shaped hole despite both of them
being superheroes the types of stories
they tell aren't anywhere close to the
same something I don't think a lot of
people understand about Marvel's output
is that they aren't superhero movies
they're movies with superheroes in them
sure and they do have consistent factors
but superhero isn't the genre instead
Marvel looks at their characters and
then writes stories about them in genres
that make sense to really explain what I
mean let's just take a look at three of
the franchises Captain America Ant-Man
and Spider-Man all three of these series
have Marvel's trademark quippy humor
costume design art Direction all that
jazz but the types of stories they're
telling are all very different Winter
Soldier and Civil War are political
Thrillers making commentary on serious
social issues this isn't Freedom there's
worse ways to protect people protection
is that how you see this he's not a U.S
citizen and they don't Grant visas to
weapons and Masters give me a break
man films are heist movies featuring
Scott Lang breaking into somewhere
highly secure to either steal something
or rescue someone my days are breaking
into places you really are done I want
you to break in the replacement steal
something and both of these franchises
are way different from the Spider-Man
movies which are all gen Z John Hughes
Coming of Age films who's this
she's the best she's awesome yeah she's
just a girl who goes to my school the
stakes are different the structures are
different the genres are different so
how does that apply to DC well Batman's
historically done this well the
Christopher Nolan Batman Trilogy are
crime Thrillers Matt Reeves is the
Batman leaned into the Noir elements of
a detective story both of them were dark
and gritty and rightfully so but the
problem begins when you start to layer
that tone across a whole franchise
Wonder Woman Shazam Superman they're not
gritty characters so trying to layer
them into gritty stories is going to
create tonal conflict this was arguably
one of the biggest issues with the early
phases of the dceu Zack Snyder's
aesthetic was being applied like a
filter over everything the genre of
those early movies was superhero comic
book and nothing really more but if you
look at the movies in the franchise that
worked the best Shazam Wonder Woman
Aquaman and The Suicide Squad they
weren't afraid to break from the mold
and carve out their own tone Wonder
Woman the good one was part period War
film part mythological epic Aquaman
borrowed a lot from Old School adventure
movies like Indiana Jones and the mummy
and audiences loved both of them ocean
Man movie has drum playing octopus
awesome kids superhero movie has YouTube
humor perfect talking shark movie has
giant alien starfish enemy cool just
because everyone in the dceu shares a
collective World it doesn't mean that
everyone's part in that world needs to
share the same tone you need to look at
the characters that you're working with
and then make movies around them not
force them into the movies that you're
trying to make so make an upbeat
Superman action film with a journalistic
subplot make a space cop action drama
with the Green Lantern just give them
all room to breathe and do their own
thing future matpat Review Time DC's
approach to this one seems perfect not
only are they letting stuff like the
Batman and Joker sit in their own worlds
with their own tone they're also
carrying over the only parts of the DC
EU that people loved Aquaman Wonder
Woman Shazam and The Suicide Squad plus
they are very clearly embracing
different tones in the new adaptations
that they're bringing to the table they
even have the same idea for that True
Detective in space version of Green
Lantern that we just pitched right there
great minds thinking alike Han James
piece of advice number four this this is
a big one take your time take your time
making the movies good duh but also more
importantly take your time announcing
what you're working on that way you can
see what works what audiences react
positively to and what you need to work
on behind the scenes if something
doesn't pan out all without publicly
embarrassing everyone involved seems
obvious right you would think but a lot
of Studios make this mistake see the MCU
had this weird marketing strategy for a
film franchise when it was still young
they'd have Kevin feige come out of
Comic Con and announce the entire next
three to five years of movies all at
once at the time when they were still
growing their brand it worked really
well for them it got fans excited which
built up hype but this taught the other
Studios the wrong lessons everyone
wanted a piece of the pie and so they
tried their best to start the next MCU
ASAP Universal might just be the best
worst example of this that I can think
of with their attempted reboot of their
classic monster movies under the Dark
Universe Banner back in the mid-2010s
they announced half a dozen movies
mapped out with a deep mythologies worth
of lore they cast Hollywood Superstars
like Tom Cruise Johnny Depp Angelina
Jolie they even released a star studied
cast photo of the major players all in
one place so you knew that they were
serious about it fun fact by the way
none of those actors were actually in
the same room for this photo shoot they
were just photoshopped together anyway
the one thing that Universal didn't do
in all this make sure the movies that
launched the franchise were actually
worth watching Dracula Untold was a
moderate financial success but was
eviscerated by critics and fans and the
mummy starring Tom Cruise it did even
worse the most memorable thing about
that movie was the trailer they
mistakenly uploaded without any audio
what the hell
uh
yep that was a real trailer uploaded by
a real major movie studio all in all
even with the exciting IP and awesome
star power they had lined up Universal
did not take their time building up this
IP and as a result people looked at the
Dark Universe and said I'm not
interested in that at all DC did the
exact same thing in 2014 they announced
10 movies for their new universe
spearheaded by Zack Snyder ranging from
Wonder Woman and Aquaman to Shazam and
Cyborg some were as far away as six
years the only problem with this they
didn't actually wait to see how people
like the first couple movies cue the
internal executive scramble Studio
interference replacing director shifting
schedules delays cancellations and
public embarrassment all of them were
self-inflicted wounds that were totally
avoidable Warner Brothers didn't need to
go out and announce 10 movies they could
have just gone with three or four seen
how people like the first stab at things
and then privately changed plans in the
background when it became clear that
audiences weren't clicking with the DC
EU this is the one that makes future map
pad a little worried I'm skeptical about
the fact that so many projects just got
announced this week another 10 in total
which is just like that initial wave of
DC EU announcements that being said I
suppose they're not completely starting
from scratch here they are bringing what
worked from the DC EU over into this new
universe so at least they're starting
out a positive note plus I also found
this quote where guns said that they're
willing to delay movies if the scripts
aren't 100 ready now I would hope that
this would normally be the default in
Hollywood but looking at Blockbusters
over the last decade clearly not but I
won't be getting too far ahead of myself
because piece of advice number five
don't have a long-term plan not kidding
don't meticulously plan out the new
universe so you know exactly what's
supposed to happen and when I know it
sounds counterproductive but I promise
that you'll regret doing this I haven't
so much of your franchise laid out you
don't give yourself room to maneuver if
something changes if a new character
pops up that you want to insert into the
franchise or a writer comes along to
offer you a great story that otherwise
doesn't fit again you can learn from
Marvel here and the big example I'm
going to point to is Captain America
Civil War this was a huge movie for the
franchise basically Avengers 2.5
featuring The culmination of a ton of
stories and setting up ton of others for
the future from the outside looking in
it might have seemed like they planned
the whole thing from the start but they
didn't Civil War wasn't even the
original pitch the writers wanted to
adapt a different Captain America story
called mad bomb but fikey didn't think
that it went big enough so things
pivoted to Civil War and even then there
were multiple versions of Civil War
floating around with and without
Spider-Man since Marvel was busy
negotiating over the character with Sony
and if they hadn't come to an agreement
there Ant-Man would have switched sides
to become team Iron Man thereby changing
his entire character Arc in all the
future movies but Marvel just decided to
go with the flow and did what worked in
the moment now that's not to say that
you shouldn't have a vague idea of what
to do or where your story is going you
100 should so you can build to it Marvel
did exactly that in Hulk and Iron Man 1
teasing The Avengers Initiative because
they knew that eventually they were
going to have a crossover they just
didn't have what was going to happen in
The Avengers laid out and then the
Avengers movie itself teased Thanos
because again Marvel knew that
eventually they'd want him to be a big
bad but writing out how exactly they
were going to get their beat for Beats
that's no bueno seriously did you know
that for a while nobody at Marvel had
decided where the Infinity Stones were
or even what was and wasn't an infinity
stone true story according to tweets
from James Gunn himself when they first
shot Guardians of the Galaxy the
infinity stone in the movie was red the
color of the reality Stone but in post
it had to be changed to the purple Power
Stone because Marvel had decided after
the fact that the red one would be
coming from Thor of the dark world's
ether heck they didn't even know why
Thanos wanted the stones to kill half
the universe until they sat down to
write the script for Infinity War I mean
if you need any more proof of their lack
of a plan they featured The Infinity
Gauntlet in Odin's vault as early as
phase one but plans changed egg and it
was retconned which when you think about
it is kind of funny because this then is
a fake of a gauntlet that hadn't even
been built yet I made what he wanted
device
capable of harnessing the power of the
stones but you know what I don't hate it
because we got a better movie franchise
out of it final future map hat review
I'm not too worried there even though
they did talk about plans to have
characters appear in multiple projects
Gunn didn't come out and announce a
giant crossover event that everything's
leading up to it seems like they're just
gonna go with the flow for now which I
think is the smart option that said
there is still one final big thing that
I want to point out to gun here so that
is a lot of advice but here's the
biggest Twist of them all DC already has
the perfect blueprint to model parts of
this new Cinematic Universe from and
it's followed basically all of this
advice it was called the DC Animated
Universe if you grew up with DC in the
90s and odds you definitely recognize
this franchise it's where a lot of the
iconic modern portrayals of DC's
characters originated Kevin Conroy's
Batman Mark Hamill's Joker those were
these versions of Batman and Joker
before they made their way into the
animated films and Arkham video games so
how does the DC Au follow my advice
let's go Point by Point firstly yes they
knew that the Heavy Hitters were
important they started this universe out
with Batman and then they grew into a
Superman show before they had the two of
them Team Up In Justice League but what
else did they do well an awesome new
character named static came along in the
comics and they jumped at the chance to
adapt him with a creative team that were
excited to tell his stories and when the
really weird but really cool idea for a
cyberpunk Batman spin-off came along
they made Batman Beyond they also let
less important characters shine in the
Justice League shows seriously Hawkgirl
the question etragram the demon all
minor characters that had leading roles
episodes even entire story arcs devoted
to them not only that but they adapted
these characters in ways that didn't
pigeonhole him into tones that didn't
fit they let Batman have a darker more
Noir tone Superman was more upbeat in
sci-fi static shock didn't feel the same
as Batman Beyond which also didn't feel
the same as Justice League fourthly they
took their time building the world
Batman the Animated Series was first
released in 1993. Superman didn't get
his spin-off until 1996 and Justice
League didn't come along until 2001. and
finally though DC Au head honcho Bruce
Tim my have had ideas on where to take
the universe's Story the creators didn't
plan beyond what seasons and shows had
already been greenlit they didn't go
into Batman in the early 90s mapping out
where their Justice League spin-off in
2005 was gonna take them listen DC James
you guys have a golden opportunity here
to take some of the most beloved
characters and IP in the world and make
something really meaningful it won't be
easy but exactly how to do it is right
in front of you all you need to do is
follow my advice just go watch some
great old cartoons in the meantime
though if you want to see my last piece
of advice that I gave to DC that they
chose not to follow check out my theory
on how they should have used the Snyder
cut to fix the DC EU timeline or if you
want to see what Batman villain DC
should have set up with the Batman check
out my theory about hush and the Joker
don't forget to subscribe for more
superhero theories coming your way soon
and as always remember it's all just a
theory a film Theory
[Music]
cuts